Blistering breaking news, guys. The New York Times actually gotten
Discord logs. We've got Discord logs. And this is where we have
first mover advantage right now, guys. Okay? Cuz guess what?
Guess who's the best at discerning Discord logs and what people
mean, and it's us, okay? You don't even have to watch Fox News.
They're not going to have any idea what what emotes mean, what
any tone indicators are, okay? They're not going to get it. That's
why you have to go to alternative media. You have to go to Twitch.
You have to go to Kick. You have to go to us to interpret this
stuff correctly. All right,
hold on. I'm going to switch over to the browser now, Jerry,
and I want you to tell me what you think of this tweet. Okay?
Cuz I don't know what to make of it. I don't know what Brian
Crassenstein's doing. Pull it up on screen here. He posts this
video, which this video is >> one of the twins, right?
>> Yes, he is one of the scammer twins. >> Okay.
Well, it's already a red flag.
He says, "The latest rumor is that Tyler Robinson's roommate,
Lance Twigs, was transgender. There is no indication that he
was transgender. Below is a video of him, and if he was transgender,
which is which there is no evidence uh where which there is no
such evidence currently, he is who helped the police catch Tyler.
He should be praised." Wait, he didn't help the police catch
Tyler. They talked to him after. I >> the the father turned
him in. >> He turned himself in. >> The father and
then if this was his roommate, it's not that he helped. you like
had no choice, right? >> Yeah. But I I just like the implication
of this video. It's like could a trans person really ride a snowboard
and do like a basic
like switch over? Is that Is this person really trans if they're
doing this on a snowboard?
>> Well, do we know what direction they're
>> Um, no we don't. Well, yeah, we do. Male to female would
be the direction. It's a male born male assigned male at birth,
you know.
>> I just I don't get this tweet makes no sense to me.
Like except sorry, it makes perfect sense in that he is totally
taking advantage of people's like preconceived notions about
trans people, right? He's totally like dude trans people trans.
>> Is that just like a whole bunch of bots? >> Possibly.
It's Brian Crassenstein. He's got a lot of followers though.
He's got like a million followers, right? 9 941,000. So >> wait,
did his about section say crypto? >> Yeah, he's a big crypto
guy. That's why I call them a scammer.
>> who's a Democrat who's a big crypto guy and that's not
a thing. >> Yeah. No, they're uh they're total grifters.
I'm I'm positive they're total grifters,
but you know, it is what it is. Anyway, uh what was I looking
for here? I was going to the reply. Somebody replies. Now, this
is this is my issue is I've seen these replies as well from the
other side where people are like, "This is his roommate. This
does not look like a transgend like transgender to you." It's
like, "No, that's a dude with a feminine features. I'm sorry."
Like, okay, that could be a picture a trans person takes, but
acting like that is proof, positive, that somebody is trans is
insane. Also,
>> no, but that is proof what they're wearing is proof
that
Oh. Oh. Notice his bulge. Like, I think that was really written
on a a bullet. I think I I think I'm seeing who wrote it. >> Oh,
yeah. No, it's I I also think they're saying he worked alone,
but I don't understand what this roommate was getting told about
the gun. Like, we're gonna have to go pick up the rifle or something.
I don't know, man.
We'll see. I think there's going to be more stuff coming out
about this. Your point, this is also him. Again, could could
a could a transgender person really stand on a snowboard?
I don't. Dude, he's like doubling down hard. >> Okay. Well,
here's this photo of him with his entire face covered. You still
think he's trans? Or is she? [__] >> Yeah.
I don't even Dude, I don't even >> You know what freaks
me out? Remember that the podcast? That's us.
The dude who says they've got she they shooters.
>> Uhhuh. Caleb something.
>> I just I've been thinking about that.
>> Yeah. Apparently um apparently Mr. Beast called that
guy to apologize for starting beef with him. >> Stop it.
>> I heard about that. heard about that yesterday. Yeah.
Yep. Mr. Beast backed >> He called him. >> Yeah.
Mr. Beast called that guy. Yeah. That guy was on some podcast.
He said, "Mr. Beast called me and apologized for like starting
beef."
>> Oh, and he he called to apologize. Oh, >> Yeah.
Like, I'm sorry. I'm sorry I started beef with you cuz uh what
were they? I think it was like Time magazine's most influential
influencers or biggest influencers. >> Number eight or
something. >> Ahead of Mr. Beast somehow.
>> I didn't get it. But he's like funny, but I don't know
if he's that funny. I don't know. >> I mean, Mr. Beast
didn't even understand why that guy was there. He's like, "Who
did I piss off?" >> Yeah. So, that's what I That's as much
as I know about that Caleb guy. All right. I just thought this
was super funny that uh was my tweet. You've seen a trans person
this radical and normal. No, obviously not. I That's like That's
objectively what the tweet is. He's like He's like assumes that
like freak is loaded into trans person and he's like this person
isn't a freak at all. Look, they're snowboarding. They're outside.
Well, don't you kind of blame this on like the
this is like the online trans movement, right? Where they they
considered everybody trans at one point? Like if you were just
like non-binary, we're going to throw you under the percentage
of people who are trans. Didn't they do that for like to broaden
support or something? >> Well, I mean, kind of. And they
I don't know if they did it broaden support. I think they
wanted to make it seem more >> but they said, "I'm not
sis. These people are not sis." And then if you think something's
someone's not cis, you're going to say trans. And it's like,
oh well, I'm non-binary. Oh, well, I'm
xeno
binary or some like that. >> Uh, cacophony just came in,
dropped a huge paragraph. I just want any proof of this, but
I'll I'll look at it. There's proof of this. Okay, it was an
MTF transgender. So, I I we will go we will go through this because
really what we're going to be walking through here is a timeline.
when this was getting reported and what information it was being
reported based on was pretty silly to me. Now, I've seen some
stuff that I I believe this guy probably was trans or is in the
process of transitioning in some way. All right. Yeah. No, I'
I've looked at all the Reddit post. Geeky Candy, that's what
I'm looking at. Okay. There. Okay. Was MTF transgender. They
were active in Discord and there has turned out to be a metric
of transgender posting. Watch what happens to Kirk tomorrow.
Which means a whole ass ring of people knew he was going to get
killed. Shot or killed shot at or 50 bucks says the FBI bust
a whole Discord trans ring.
>> Discord trans ring is crazy. That was a
right there. >> Take the bet. 50 bucks. Oh, I'm not going
to take that bet. >> No. Huh? I'm way more confident that
this guy isn't a groper than I am that uh there won't be like
a group of Discord people who were talking about this this person
getting shot. Charlie Kirk getting shot. Oh, Buttniff is still
here coping today. That's unlucky. Unfortunate for you, Buttniff
is still here coping today.
It's fine. Get ready to pay. Wait, didn't Axios already break
the reporting on this? I I haven't gone to it yet cuz I'm I'm
trying to roll into this slowly. But that Axios basically already
broke the reporting.
Is this I mean break by breaking the reporting are you breaking
that it's misinfo because
>> I feel like a pixie on my timeline saying that this
is just mainstream media lying again for the third time. >> Yeah,
I know it's Pix. Listen, it is what it is. Okay, I'm not going
to
>> uh let's see here. Okay, this is the Axio reporting
from earlier today. This is like two hours ago. Tops Kirk suspects
Kirk suspects transgender roommate Aast may be key to motive.
So, this is just some reporting from Axio. Okay. Authorities
are investigating whether Tyler Robinson, suspected of Charlie
Kirk, believed Kirk's views on gender identity were hateful to
people like Robinson's transgender roommate. Six sources familiar
with the case tell Axios. Why it matters. Investigators believe
Robinson's anger at Kirk's views could be key a key to establishing
a motive for the slaying of the controversial activist whose
death sent shock waves through American politics. Each of the
six sources familiar with the investigation told Axios that investigators
believe Robinson had a romantic relationship with his roommate.
Zoom in. Axios' sources said investigators initially wanted the
information about the roommate's gender identity kept quiet because
that person is being extremely cooperative with authorities.
Yeah, I it does, Shimu. It does. By the way, like a lot of people
don't want it to be a trans person cuz they're like that that's
going to prove Dude, it doesn't matter if it's a trans person.
You still don't like take away trans people's rights. You still
like push back against that. It's like it's not, oh, if this
person was trans or if they had like a trans roommate and they
were Charlie Kirk because they thought he was anti-trans. You
don't actually like stop defending trans people because that
happened. That's crazy. >> When a trans person murders
somebody, it's okay to shun that individual and to criticize
them. >> Also, that yes, when is the right ever been reasonable?
They're not. They're not. But >> yeah, you definitely make
fun of them. That they're not reasonable, Zortician. But they
are the people you like you see ground to them when you just
lie to pretend that they're wrong, right? Don't just lie and
make up to like be like, "Oh, I I I think they're wrong. I'm
pretty sure they're wrong." Don't do that. Obviously, you just
seed a bunch of ground to them. >> This is um Wait, wait,
is this a chorus rapid media response? >> Oh god, I sure
hope not. I sure I sure hope not. >> Who are the posters?
Let's get their >> dude. Sometimes sometimes saying like
let's get their names. Uh people take that the wrong way now.
That's not what I mean. I mean like usernames on the
>> Yeah. [__] Is that Never mind. You can't
say anything today. >> Jesus Benny. This is so gay.
>> Benny
burning buildings of uh employers who are refusing to fire people.
And JC's like, "No, don't tweet that. They're going to ban your
account."
I Okay, first of all, I wanted to tweet that first while something
like that and then I was like, "Oh, if I tweet that, I was going
to tweet it in an anti- Charlie Kirk way." I was going to take
credit for like, you see all those people saying they got people
fired? I wanted to tweet something like, "I'm proud to say that
I've burned down 13 businesses who fired people for negative
comments towards Charlie Kirk and I've got more on my list or
some [__] like that." It's like, just say say some
[__] like that cuz it's like, dude, why are you why
are you going insane? I I just hate the cat. >> Mind you,
the joke is the joke is quite literally funny because no one's
doing >> or because you don't do it. >> You ruin
jokes when you guys act like insane people in real life. Not
Not you guys, of course. The people in the what's it called?
The Discord trans rings. Those people. >> The Discord trans
rings. Oh boy. Oh boy. All right. What else do we got? Oh, sorry.
I need to keep reading this article. The roommate was a gasast
at the slaying when speaking to investigators and shared electronic
messages sent by Robinson. One of the sources said that's what
happened. Oh my god, no. The roommate said, according to the
source, here are all the messages. The phone messages indicated
a sender listed as Tyler had mentioned that after the shooting,
he had wrapped his rifle in a towel and stashed it in some bushes
near Utah Valley University where the shooting occurred. Governor
Spencer Cox said Friday during a news conference. Tyler also
told the roommate in writing that the rifle would have been would
have to be retrieved. [__] said between the lines.
Oh, go ahead. >> Hold on. I want to reply to somebody in
chat. Uh, Kringle says, "Is there a certain level of praise or
encouragement that warrants a firing?" I think that if your job
has anything to do with public safety, I think if people's lives
are in your hands in any way, shape, or form, then yeah, it warrants
firing. I think something happened with like pilots praising
somebody's death or like you don't want to see your doctors,
your nurses, your pilots, your like
police officers, your firefighters praising the death of somebody
who has like a different political ideology than you. >> Yeah.
I would also add like people who put their employer like in their
Twitter handle and then they tweet really unhinged like you're
taking your life in your own hands. I I probably would argue
you shouldn't be fired, but like if you do get fired, I >> it
has to be your job has to be relevant for the reason why people
are uh really disappointed. Yeah. Teacher probably counts too.
But if you like hypothetical you work for Dunder Mifflin,
what what is that thing called? >> Dunder Mifflin.
>> Yeah. If you work for Dunder Mifflin Paper Company,
you've got the type of job where it's perfectly fine for you
to probably be a insensitive bigot without losing your job. Sorry.
>> Yeah, but if you put if you put Dunder Mifflin in there
and you like give people traction to like go after you, if they
have to dox you to find your job and then they get you fired,
I think that's I think those people shouldn't be fired. I think
if they're operating under like pseudo anonymity and and I I
think they're totally fine to say whatever they want. But if
>> but I I also think that it's it's that
choice to say I don't care about his personal political beliefs
outside of here even if he puts his info on his account. Right.
And you >> supposed to take you are supposed to boycott
by not buying from that company. >> Him being a bigot does
not personally affect your life. You just want to take your anger
out on him. if it if his job has nothing to do with needing his
ideology
to be like um
I don't know to not be a concern for like yours or the people
around you's safety. I don't understand getting people fired.
>> Yeah, sure. I think the issue for me is the the jobs
don't stand up for that. Like the jobs could do it, but the jobs
will never stand up. The jobs will always fire the person essentially,
>> right? It's it's like never ever worth the backlash
at any big company ever. It's pretty dumb cuz I feel like they
fire people before they even feel it in their pockets, right?
Nobody's financially like boycotting
McDonald's. >> Dude, this cacophony guy just came back
and said he gave one Twitter handle that apparently knew beforehand
about Charlie Kirk
and he he was saying there's a huge ring and all this other bro,
I posted an archive. Wait, where did you post the archive? Hold
on. He said he posted an archive. Where did you post this? Are
you talking about that photo of the person who said Charlie Kirk's
going to his university and that something huge is going to happen
the next day? >> Um, maybe. I don't know exact to be >> Dick
Masterson retweeted too. I think I saved those tweets if you
didn't see >> Uh, I did not. Um, I can't click on that
archive link so that sucks. I just always get I always get giga
my archive links now.
Every archive site just doesn't allow either the VPN I'm using
or it just straight up doesn't work at all.
I have no idea how to make these things like work in any way.
It's always goofy. Yeah, I just get blocked. It's like an engine
X routing question or routing rule. Okay, hold on. We've got
an imager album. Hold on. Oh, this is one picture. Uh you you
guys, I have something big coming soon. Just be sure to check
the news. You'll know it when you see it. Well, that's that.
Okay, so they tweeted this out and then they at some indeterminate
time later that if you think this is proof of something, you
are sub I don't know what to tell you, bro.
That's rough. That's rough. That's rough. That's rough. Anyway,
I I'll just keep reading the actual article of stuff. Okay, so
the the roommate was cooperative, guys. Okay. Phone messages
indicated a sender listed as Tyler Oh. to retrieve the gun. Tyler
also told the roommate in writing that the rifle would have to
be retrieved. Federal and state law enforcement officials are
also examining leftist groups in Utah to see what whether they
had knowledge of the alleged shooters plans beforehand or if
they lent material support to him afterward. One of those groups
eliminated social media profile after the shooting. Axios has
learned the motive and political ideology of Robinson, 22, are
subjects of intense online debate. Some conservatives have insisted
he's an unhinged leftist. Liberals have pushed back by pointing
to Robinson's conservative upbringing in Utah.
In the a Daily Mail uh in a Daily Mail interview Friday, family
matriarch Debbie Robinson said the family supports President
Trump's MAGA movement. Most of my family members are Republican.
She said, "I don't I don't know any single one who's a Democrat."
This is the grandma. This the grandma interview. Family members
have told reporters that Tyler Robinson had become more political
in recent years and had expressed interest in Kirk's visit to
the Utah Valley campus in Oram, Utah. Cox said a Robinson family
member had told investigators that the accused shooter recently
had a conversation in which someone said Kirk was spreading hate
and was full of hate. And it was unclear, but it was unclear.
Sorry, from Cox's remarks who actually made that statement. It
wasn't unclear. It was clear it was the other family member.
Actually, LGBTQ activists have criticized media outlets for erroneously
reporting in the hours after the shooting that a bullet casing
from the scene including uh included a message related to transgender
people. That did happen. That is misinformation that got posted.
very unfortunate. So surprised how conservatives switch up on
going after people's jobs. I thought this was one of the principles
they hold on to. Yeah, dude. It's it's actually so unprincipled.
It's like it's it it's so frustrating to see, right? That like
people I swear to God, one of the people who got fired, one of
the people they went after was someone who posted wamp wamp in
response to Charlie Kirk dying. Wamp wamp. Like really? That's
That's the line that feels like that can't possibly be the case,
right? Like that's an insane level to operate at. Wait, where
do I have I swear to God I have that thing on my soundboard.
>> I've lost it.
There we go. Thank you. All right. It's pretty clear that Robinson's
roommate knew a lot and didn't say anything after the So, they're
a person of interest officially and are cooperating. Second official
said we want to keep it that
So, the interesting thing here is I haven't seen like a lot of
hard evidence in this. It's saying like what the investigators
are looking into. So, I I don't see like hard evidence of what
it actually is, right? Am I crazy? Anyone else see that >> evidence
of what? >> Oh, I don't see hard evidence that this person
was uh that like they were mad at Charlie Kirk about his trans
rhetoric or anything like that. They're saying they're going
that way. Um that's probably not what it was cuz actually, cuz
I think that's explicitly wrong, just so you know. It's not the
markings. It was the It was the writing, the engraving on them
that he did. >> I mean, I would imagine if your roommate
and I don't know, are they just roommates or are they partners?
>> Well, there's no proof of anything there >> Okay.
Because
I would just like to say most of the people who were up in arms
and starting fires over the George Floyd riots, the BLM riots,
th those were white people. You know what I mean? It's every
white person who got a black friend or a white person who got
a white friend who's dating a black person. >> Sure. I
wouldn't I wouldn't like write off the fact that this like sis
white dude has like six degrees of I'm outfit you for your trans
rhetoric. I don't
>> He could. So, what am I looking for here? Oh, yeah.
It wasn't that dick tweet. I I
I guess yeah, that tweet that tweet is kind of spooky.
That could be something they're referring to.
But yeah, that that tweet went far. >> Uh let's see here.
I'm looking for I've lost a thread here that I had a thread that
was talking about basically like some of the misinfo around the
person being trans and I cannot find it now. I'm looking. I'm
looking. There was a there was like a big thread of the person
going like this is what they actually Oh, here it is.
Oh, but it's this guy. I don't trust anything this guy says.
This guy's a
This guy is like a very stupid person. That's the dick tweet.
Yeah, this is I'll pull it up on stream really quick before we
move on. This is the tweet from a couple days ago. This was a
trans
Um, what? Charlie Kirk is coming to ch to my college tomorrow.
I really hope someone evaporates him literally. Let's just say
something big will happen >> You said this was a trans
person. Are they no longer trans? >> Wait, did I say was?
Didn't mean to say was. Or when I read the tweet, maybe is where
I'm going backwards. >> Oh, gotcha. Gotcha. Okay. >> Okay.
Adam Cochran posted this. Let's see. Oh, man. Where are his facts
coming from? Well, there uh so one of seven. Well, there we go.
Some uh some clarity from Daily Mail of all places. Tyler splits
a three-bedroom apartment with his roommates. One guy one is
a guy who desperately wants to be a pro gamer streamer pro gaming
streamer and may be transidentifying may. That person was cooperative
with police. But
>> but this roommate Lance was also the one who claimed
to have Discord messages from Tyler about the shooting. Discord
proved he did not. Discord did not prove he did not. Discord
just said he did not. messages referenced in uh recent reporting
about planning details do not appear to be Discord messages.
These were communications between the suspect's roommate and
a friend after the shooting where the roommate was recounting
the contents of a note the suspect had left elsewhere. We found
no evidence that the Okay, hold on. So, this was I believe they
talked about text messages as well. Right. Anyway, they talked
about test text messages, but I don't I don't know this this
is like a total nonsequator. It doesn't even need to be added.
It doesn't add anything to anything.
the Daily Mail piece. If he's just going to cut and paste all
parts from this Daily Mail >> It looks like he's going
from a couple different places. This first one was just the Daily
Mail piece. None of the rest of the stuff is, as far as I know.
>> Um 37. There's no indication on social media for Lance
or Tyler that they're in a relationship. In fact, nothing shows
them ever interacting in Lance's profiles, which were still open,
show no connection with any profiles of Tyler. Although, I have
we found any profiles of the Tyler guy? I feel like the profiles
of the Tyler guy are just gone. Like maybe he wiped them preemptively
or something. But I don't think we've seen any actual social
media presence from the Tyler guy. >> Isn't this also something
that could be possible if you have a very online present family
who's very right-wing and you are maybe a lot more left than
your family is.
You're you're probably not going to have an online social media
presence that's tied to your real life
>> or that would be tied to you dating a trans person.
Yeah, you wouldn't give that to like a family that's going to
go and look that stuff up. Yeah, I would imagine.
>> It's not to say that they're closeted, that they just
don't want problems with their family, right? >> Yeah.
Yeah, that makes some sense. Hey, damn. I just wish uh nothing.
Never mind. Uh there is no confirmation that Lance is trans.
Lance's identity was revealed in a separate report in separate
reporting and the trans component seems to have come from appearance
and gamer tags, not any self-declaration.
Now, the thing about this is is there's a Reddit account that
was found and that Reddit account does
to correspond to users usernames this Lance Sky used and it also
seems to be talking about them being trans,
right? So, it's not a perfect match because the names aren't
perfect matches, but it is a person with a very he uses the name
Lancelot in a lot of different places, different formations of
Lancelot.
And this Lancelot person was posting on Reddit posting about
being ex-Christ Christian and they're from Utah. So, it's uh
it's a little
>> I don't think that's very reliable. Um it's pretty reliable
in my opinion. Go ahead, J. >> Is he the one that wants
to be a >> I don't know. So, it seems that way. Yeah, it
seems that way. >> Okay. Because man, I'm making connections
I shouldn't be making right now. You're saying that there's like
Reddit posts or whatever. Has has Flamco been in their comments
under any of the
Christian subreddits?
>> I don't know. I have not tracked all of Flamco's Reddit
identities. That would be impossible. >> Okay. Okay.
>> Yeah.
So, so at best, Lance maybe had a housemate who was maybe trans,
but has already made multiple statements to law enforcement that
do not seem to be accurate. What? This guy's a goof. And I'm
not sure about the rest of you, but I've certainly had roommates
that I disliked, were crazy, and didn't politically align with
me over the years. So to jump from this reporting by the Daily
Mail to he was he is a trans lover is insane.
This will be the same case as the bullet casings. Some dumbass
in the cash FBI saw minor detail, extrapolated to a political
extreme, leaked it to the press, and we'll backtrack it. Meanwhile,
MAGA will run with it. So that has happened. I don't think that's
like totally crazy to think that this could be what's happening
here, but I think there's some other stuff going on that >> Steve
Crowder >> means me in the previous direction. Yeah, Steven
Crowder's
also noticed the ad for the rental said current owner has roommates
and so the remaining two bedrooms for $900 a month. This is a
student dorm like setup with 3 to six people living there, three-bedroom
place, and owner has roommates plural in one room and then rents
two more out. Plus, it's worth mentioning,
dude.
Oh,
I can see exactly this is like there's a bunch of copers in my
Discord, too, who keep linking this guy. It's very, very, very
funny.
There's a bunch of copers in my Discord who keep linking this
guy. Also, guys, Nick Fentes loves fanboys. He loves catboys.
Okay, so like this guy, maybe they are lovers. I know I just
dis I know I just said there's no way they were lovers or something,
but maybe they are lovers, but maybe that also proves he's more
of a groper now. Actually, actually, he's totally not. He's totally
not trans. He's totally not gay. He's totally not anything. He
might even hate this guy, but also he might be his lover and
then that would prove he's a groper, too. Oh my. You guys getting
it? Are you guys getting this? I don't know if would feel weird
to cope like this over uh on social media. I just feel odd. Uh
anyway, animal her animal hoodie means he was a gay trans furry.
This guy is just boxing with a lot of shadows. Damn. Okay. >> Is
being a furry a type of trans? >> I don't think so. No,
I don't believe so. I don't think you would argue that. >> Okay.
I would never make that argument. >> I'm just asking questions.
>> So, let me see here. Where do we go from there? I think
O posted the Yeah, this would be Fox News running with the
>> alert. FBI sources tell Fox News Digital that the man
charged with assassinating Charlie Kirk was living with a transgender
partner. Bureau officials confirmed that Tyler Robinson was in
a romantic relationship with someone transitioning from male
to female.
So this to me when they're just saying FBI sources tell us that
seems like that's a way different level of claim than other things
being claimed, right? They say that individual is fully cooperating
with their investigation, claims to have had no idea of Robinson's
plans, and is not currently accused of any criminal activity.
>> This is way different and it is mainstream media. It's
not like Fox has ever been taken to court for blatantly lying
to the American people for um like partisan political purposes.
>> Uh, sure.
But I think, didn't that like cost them a couple hundred million
>> Oh, no. Yeah, that exact thing happened. I forgot. Yeah,
>> it did. Yeah. No, it did happen, but it like cost them
a lot of money. They have to report someone else. >> A
lot of money.
>> They're Yeah, it did. They're not >> But you understand
you you can say that it cost them a lot of money, but how often
have they done it? And how much is the fact that Tucker Carlison
Tucker Carlson like leaked parts of it the reason why
all of that fell apart? Like for all you know they are welloiled
machine because they do like that. >> I I think from the
depositions and stuff there's a lot of other people than Tucker
Carlson. I think there was a lot of people there who were talking
about it and like about it >> cuz I think >> for
for all the bad things that happened it is like a journalist
organization. They don't want to be like lying. They at least
like Tucker does an opinion thing, but they don't want to be
lying to people like knowingly lying. Like that's a very different
thing. >> They're a half journalist uh network, right?
They do have opinionated.
>> They do have opinion uh like opinion videos, but this
is not um this not like their opinion stuff, right? This is like
their actual newsroom. >> Correct. Correct. And you would
assume after the Tucker Carlson thing that they wouldn't be making
that mistake so soon
>> Yeah. Yeah. Uh Casey Lee IRL actually makes a good point
that if you were going to actually distrust somebody here, you
actually probably do trust that Fox does have a source in the
FBI. You just don't trust the FBI. The Cash Patel, okay, the
DI FBI is uh not trustworthy at this point. That's the problem,
actually. Jesus Christ. That's scary, isn't it? Like that's actually
the weak link here. Fox News has a far better I'm way more trusting
of Fox News citing a source than I am of the FBI saying some
fact that they're they're claiming from an investigation.
What a [__] up world. What an what an absolutely
world,
dude. That's that's that's crazy. Actually, >> FBI who
them they they broke records the time the turnaround time that
the FBI and their police contacts in Utah
found the suspect. They did it themselves. They paved the way.
I can't trust those
>> We We had 10,000 leads. We had 10,000 leads. Okay. Like,
how did that help you?
Uh, >> yeah. The dad called in. He told us that he got
the he got the he got the person. It's a son. >> Um, yeah.
Yeah. Maximus, just to be clear, Crowder did not report off of
FBI sources. He reported off of ATF sources. And the ATF sources,
any journalist, anybody involved with any of that to tell you,
you don't take like incident reports that are unverified by anyone.
It's just somebody writing down what they think, right? You don't
take those incident reports and publish them as fact. You'd have
to be a complete to do that. People took him seriously after
that tweet. They can all be considered Wait, after which tweet?
Which tweet was this? Let me help you out. Bellacha is an anti-fascist
song. People like Fentes have called Kirk a liberal in disguise
and a fascist. The comment on the bulge is derogatory statement
against trans people. The if you're reading this, you're gay.
Lauo is not progay. Okay.
The arrows and iron sights on the bullets are different from
the messages on the casings. And it's now clear how the reports
got mixed up and why we shouldn't have had partial reports. This
guy was clearly a Groper who thought Kirk wasn't conservative
enough. Here's info about the Gropers.
Dude, the the best part of this Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This is
um Groper Wars America First. This is some guy named AF. 52 songs,
291 saves on this playlist. Okay. And they've got one version
of Bellachia on here. Okay. I This guy, can we find this guy's
post in 2016? I feel like I know for a fact I feel like I can
state factually right now that this is one of the dudes who is
posting the math on how Bernie Sanders makes a comeback in the
2016 Democratic
>> Like 100 I'm 100% positive that's what this guy was
doing in 2016. >> Robbed him. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
It's like Bernie can still win. Actually, all Bernie has to do
is like win California. He's used to run the table in these states.
Okay. He could still do it. And then the superdelegates can go
against Hillary Clinton and we can actually have Bernie Sanders
as the nominee for the Democratic party. Koser
Koser's in the chat known uh known Groper Lieutenant. Okay, little
inside info. We've never heard of this playlist before. No one
I know has heard of this playlist. Okay,
>> what playlist?
>> Oh, the one we looked at, the Spotify one just down
here >> that like uh people were saying, "Oh, there's a
mic from PA tweet. I've seen some millennials saying that Bellachow
song being on the casing means that the 22-year-old was a leftist.
Here's a remix of Bella Chow on the Groper War America verse
playlist. Groper war refers to their targeting of Charlie Kirk.
It does actually. It does. That is what the Groper War was about,
dude. It's uh it's a little crazy. There's an article stating
Tyler was dating Lance per a family member of Lance's that was
interviewed. Oh, really? I've not seen that article yet. But
also, I'm starting to get a little suspect of like that, too.
Like I wonder if that wouldn't get put out into the ether because
people want it out in the ether like like a family member is
just like yeah no they were totally dating without really thinking
about it or looking at it. I don't know. What is this? I do I
have another Adams Cochran. >> Oh this playlist
it only has 30
>> Well it's got what 291 saves. I don't know how many
people would have been listening to it at any given time. Um
looks like it was updated somewhat recently. Huh. Salivation
links. What is this? What is this? What is this? Okay.
Why did you link this? Why did you just link this? I don't understand
why you linked a video of Charlie Kirk's widow d crying. What
is the blueberry fund? A blueberry fund is probably people like
is probably a thing you do with your kid. You say you could go
get blueberries.
You get like blueberries. Fruit is like candy for little kids.
What do you mean? What is
>> No, those are those are Hold on. I got this. Okay. Those
are suburban white people and they go pick fruit for fun over
the weekends. After you pick the fruit, you have to pay for it
by the >> Hold on a second. See this? Apparently, this
is uh something with one of Lance Twigs's uh family members.
Lance Twigs was named as the roommate of accused. So, this is
on Wisconsin.com.
So, I don't know how reputable this is. We can check it out.
Let's look. Last Twigs was named as the roommate of accused Charlie
Kirk assassin Tyler Robinson by the New York Post and Daily Mail.
After those reports, Wisconsin right now reached out reached
two family members of Twigs by phone on September 13th. The first
family member declined to comment and hung up. The second family
member confirmed the information in the post and Daily Mail stories,
but also provided additional details to Wisconsin right now that
no one has reported. For starters, the family member who's spoken
to other members of the news media, alleged that Twigs harbored
animosity towards conservatives and Christians, confirmed that
Twigs was
and said Robinson was allegedly Twig's boyfriend. To be clear,
authorities have not accused Lance Twigs of criminal wrongdoing
or culpability in connection with Kirk's death. A roommate was
me uh sorry, a roommate was mentioned in Utah's the Utah governor's
press conference, although he was not named. The governor said
the roommate gave authorities messages from Robinson that referred
to a rifle and bullet engravings. They did live together. The
family member of Lance Twigs told Wisconsin right now in the
uh in the exclusive phone interview on September 13th, referring
to Twigs and Robinson. He Lance Twigs is very angry with anyone
who's supportive of conservative ideals and Christian values,
alleged the family member. Now,
this is like helpful, but just hold on a second here. Okay, guys,
hold on. I want to believe this cuz it would make me a lot of
money, okay? But I also have to think of like how conservative
family members like very very very deeply religious or conservative
family members might see you as like somebody who's not, you
know, if you were like a liberal even and how they might describe
some of your beliefs, right?
Like I I don't know, man.
I don't know. I need to also, I guess, see how they reach this
family member because it's Wisconsin right now. I don't know
this I don't know this publication.
I don't know who they are. Was it a groper? Uh, Zanjage, I've
got I think 200 bucks or so in bets saying it's not a groper,
but we'll we'll see. A lot of people claiming that. Is there
anyone named as the source? They say it's a family member. So,
uh, as far as I know, still the family member they're talking
to. As far as I know, he was not going by another name. I just
know he was in the process of transitioning. I know he was trying
to make take different medications, alleged the relative of Lance,
whom the family member had avoided for about 4 years out of concern
over Twigs's alleged temperament. The relative told Wisconsin
right now about having heard secondhand from other family members
that Lance had allegedly wished horrible things on people. I've
really distanced. There was allegedly there was allegedly evil
inside and only getting worse. A Fox. Yeah, I'm I'm seeing this
as like >> evil inside. >> Yeah, I'm I'm getting
the feeling that this is like a deeply religious and conservative
family member who like hates him.
Um probably for just not, you know, respecting the rest of the
beliefs of the family. Oh, that's Well, that's not even hating
him. It's like they don't want to hate him, so they have to assume
like a demon or the devil. Evil has consumed him.
That's >> how they
Yeah. Fox News journalist reported via sources on September 13th
that Robinson was living with a transgender roommate, but did
not name the roommate. Robinson was living with a transgender
partner who was in the process of transitioning from male to
female. The post confirmed the post. So, I think that the New
York Post reporting on this has been extremely suspect from what
I've seen. Like, their sourcing is bad. They're sourcing people
who don't have sources and stuff. So, anything that's involving
the New York Post with regards to this, I'm extremely suspect
of. It's a little concerning. K. >> This is It's kind of
like when Megan Markle first
I think when it was first announced that she was dating Which
Prince is it? Harry. >> Uh, Harry. No.
>> The Ginger. >> Or was it Prince William?
>> Which one? Which one? She got the more attractive one,
right? Or is she with the ugo? >> Uh,
Vans. >> Okay. Either way, when that happened, they like
reached out to her aranged father who was like who fled to Mexico
and never play paid child support and her crippled wheelchair
ridden sister who was like spiteful of her and everything that
she's done. Like they just reach out to the people who are going
to give you the juiciest scoop on that person. No regards for
them or the truth. Yeah. And I think I think like at least with
that you could you could almost think I'd be like more trusting
of that because of some worry about getting sued with this stuff.
I don't think they're worried about getting sued by this guy
and his like uh his religious family either. Right. So it's already
bad enough when they like have some threat coming back at them
from like the royal family. But this I just think they totally
make [__] up. Yeah. Uh Tam unfortunately now there's
like a whole bunch of sourcing for all of this stuff. Like the
Axio piece had six sources. They said there just seemed to be
a lot of sourcing for all of this. Wait, I'm not giving you odds.
Buttsniff, I already offered you better odds. You said you would
donate. We already have a bet. You said you would donate if you're
wrong. We already have the bet, >> dude. He's just doing
that. So, you keep saying butt sniffer through your
>> Sure. Sure. Haven't seen a single source
>> Yeah. Yeah. Haven't seen a single source. Not going
to lie. Uh the issue is is when we have reliable journalistic
like publications and Fox News's factual reporting is quite good,
right? When you have them citing the FBI, I'm going to take that
as them having a source. I don't need to see proof. I don't want
to see proof of that. I don't need to. That's like that's literally
just a journalistic publication saying we have a source on this.
You do take their word for it. Fox News is factual. I understand
that Fox News's opinion reporting is their factual reporting
like their articles and [__] and their like breaking
news segments where they report actual events. That is not as
anyway. So we have this shaken relative who almost broke down
into tears at one point during the interview asked not to be
named. Wisconsin right now tracked down the family member through
data mining sites that showed the familiar linkage to Twigs.
The relative alleged that Lance Twigs is not mentally well at
all. Asked whether Lance was transgender and transitioning, the
family member alleged, "This is true. I can't be sure of when
it started. I have suspicions it would be have been about 4 years.
The family member alleged to Wisconsin right now that Robinson
was Lance Twigs's boyfriend. I knew he had a boyfriend. I never
met him. None of us had. The relative was not sure how long they
were together. Asked how the relative knew Robinson was allegedly
Lance Twig's boyfriend. The relative responded, "Lance disclosed
that not directly to me. He wanted to have lunch with other family
members to introduce his boyfriend." The relative said the uh
the relative said the relative had avoided doing anything uh
having anything to do with Lance Twigs for about four years.
Ah man, I know the reason I had nothing to do with him is that
he Lance Twigs was is full of evil and hatred. The family member
alleged about Lance Twigs. Well, this is extremely shocking.
I was afraid he might hurt someone. The family member alleged
saying the belief was based on things he would say to family
members. The relative declined to be more specific. Ah, man.
I This is like uh I don't know how seriously I take this. I'm
sorry. I It's whatever. I just I don't think you'd really take
it that seriously. I would like to, but it they like reached
out to this person. They said, "Oh, we haven't talked to them
in years." It's Mormon coded as Yeah, but it's not truth coded
as I understand that it could be Mormon coded. Doesn't seem like
truth coded. It seems like I had a bad feeling about this person
and so I didn't want to interact with them. I could believe they're
a family member. I don't believe that they have a good idea of
what's going on in the guy's life. I just don't believe that.
Anyway, what are we continuing on to here, guys? What else we
got? I think in a little bit we might go over some of the stuff
like basically people are posting a bunch of Charlie Kirk's um
oh what do you call it his like old positions and
I kind of wanted to go through some of them and just see I don't
know we'll just we'll see what some of the crazy he's saying
is technically the Fox reporter isn't claiming their sources
in the FBI. Um well no no the old Fox reporting but the most
recent one. This one is directly >> a Fox News alert. FBI
sources tell Fox News Digital that the >> Tell Fox News
Digital. This is not the same reporting as the Brook Singman
thing. This is different reporting. I understand that people
do not like the Brook Sigman thing. I've I've looked into that,
right? I understand that. But this is not Fox News sourcing this
person. So, here she is 4 hours ago actually updating and saying
FBI senior officials confirmed Charlie Kirk's assassin Tyler
Robinson was in a romantic relationship with transgender partner.
This is like a different thing. So, as bad as like herit was,
right, and that everybody was sourcing her, um, it now seems
like the FBI has confirmed this directly to Fox News. Yes, we
we get it. Yes, Kger, this is true that Fox News is actually
the reliable person here. The thing that's not reliable in this
case,
I kind of should say the thing that's actually unreliable in
this case is the FBI. Yoshi, he's carrying it in his pants. It's
probably why it looks like he's walking with a limp the whole
time. That's what I think that's what we're deciding. Also, he
dis Oh, it might be in his backpack. He had a screwdriver up
there with him. So, people think he dismantled it right after
making the shot. Took the shot, immediately dismantled with a
screwdriver, packed it away, ran. Yeah.
>> What is that thing where
um there's like some sort of weapon, some like ultrasonic weapon
to drive people crazy? Um, are you talking about the Havana syndrome
stuff that people thought Russia developed? >> Yeah. Yeah.
Do we do we know if that happened to Cash Patel? Because that
could explain a lot. Him thinking that he's going to Valhalla,
that he's going to be in like white supremacy heaven with Charlie
Kirk. >> I don't know if that explains it. I don't know.
I don't think that would explain it. I think it just makes >> something
happened to him. um >> that he's in some sort of get out
trap right now and they've like upped it like a a camera flash
doesn't set it off now. I don't know who needs to do what to
snap him the out of it, but that mother is trapped. I think I
think he is just like I think you you might have had it um you
might have had it the other day when you were talking about how
um like I think it's possible that there are just a lot of white
supremacists in the FBI and he's like basically like a >> he
is basically
>> Yeah. He's basically like a gazelle walking through
like a pack of lions right now and that's why his eyes are constantly
popping out of his head. >> He just knows at any moment
he could get taken out for anything.
Terrifying. Have you have you ever seen the movie Get
>> Yeah. Oh, I'm compounding on that because I also feel
like he's in a sunken place. Like his eyes look like he is at
the bottom in a dark pit screaming for someone to get him out.
>> Yeah. It's just that it's only coming through his eyes.
He's It's not coming through his mouth at all. >> It's
only coming through his eyes. Yeah. >> His mouth is still
spewing complete. >> Okay. Yeah, I can [__]
with that. He's pretty interesting. Okay. Cherries teaspoon.
Yeah, >> this was the big thread of people tracking this
guy's like identities across different platforms. This Lancelot
with two T's was something he'd used on other platforms as well.
They tracked this guy's like u they tracked his username across
multiple platforms and they do find that he's doing like transdy
stuff earlier this year.
Um what else is there? It's like transdiy
Oh no way. Oh, no. Never mind. These are the most visited subreddits.
Was this Lancelot 3? Okay. Was the one now? Man, I'm I'm trying
to think of if I could find like the post where they explain
the usernames cuz they do say somewhere down here how they track
the usernames specifically.
I'm trying to find it. Hold on. Let me see this Thread Reader
app thing. No, the Destiny lore things actually about the video
game. Oh, there's that and then there's this. Hold on. Let's
check this out. It's apparently new surveillance video of this
guy walking to campus. That's tremendously boring. There's literally
nothing. This is just a dude walking in shorts and a hat. Jesus.
Just nothing new, eh? He switched clothes. So yeah, apparently
he walked to the campus, got close, switched clothes, and then
as soon as he like was running away, he switched back into these
clothes. We knew that though from before. We knew that he'd switch
clothes. I'm not sure how much of this I want to go read. I do
think I want to read a decent amount of it though. Okay, let's
uh let's go to the top. Let's go to the top here and check it
out. The Reddit account of the roommate. Frequent flyer of r/4ran.
Previous posts about HRT and other fetish related things. Path
to discovery. Facebook, Instagram, Tik Tok, Steam, alternative
user handle list, searched Reddit. Voila. So that's how they
found him. Just tracking like a couple different tags and then
looking at multiple usernames from Steam and then looking for
those usernames on other sites. And like when you go from that,
you you track those usernames, you find somebody who is, you
know, fitting the vibe of like a bunch of other things. They
say they're from the same state. It's like not 100%.
It just like happens to get there. It's currently live. Okay.
Confirmation of Utah. I literally could drive to Arizona right
now and it would be the exact same temperature as my city, Utah.
A 20-mi stretch doesn't suddenly make the temperature change.
Okay. Thank you for the four-year drawn out argument about Utah.
I guess which direction is this? 100°. This is just them talking
about being in Utah. Okay, this is a genuine question. Why does
it matter if you happen uh to you if a teenager decides they're
transgender and goes through the transition in the case that
happened and when courts asked the father not to speak about
it presumably so the kid wasn't bullied, he ignored them. I used
to be extremely openly transphobic and have grown out of it as
well as met some other nice trans uh transgender individuals.
If your reason is that the child is ruining their body, that's
100% their choice and it doesn't affect you. I generally want
to know why you're so strongly opinionated on this because I've
seen you in multiple threads on the sub bringing up the same
court case. So arguing, you know, protran stuff on Reddit, I
guess
this more of the like active in Okay. r/cryptids.
Oh, r/ Jordan Peterson. Did Jordan Peterson push this person
to convince their roommate to commit violence?
>> Is that is that the question? >> Taking a break.
Is he back yet?
>> I don't know if he's break. I don't know if he's back.
Uhoh. Uhoh.
Magic the Gathering. He plays Commander. Yeah, it's over. Okay,
it's over. This is definitely the guy. >> You You have
Magic the Gathering cards.
>> Yeah, that's why I know this guy's got some unhealthy
thoughts. >> I need to be concerned about you. >> Oh
god, Stormlight, too. >> What's Stormlight?
>> Uh, fantasy series. Oh, more more active
Misborn Brandon Sanderson fan lo memes.
I'm just going to keep looking like Brandon Sanderson.
>> Germma fan. Well, I'm not a German fan. Okay. Moist
Critical subreddit. Dude, who who goes to Moist Critical's >> I
don't even think Moist Critical goes >> That's crazy. Uh,
let's see. Transdy
>> What is Germa? >> Uh, German is just a streamer.
It's just a guy. >> Okay. Keep looking through here. To
be fair, some nights the injection just sucks. Like, it just
sucks so bad. Seriously, sometimes it's just muscle memory. Sometimes
I got to get buzzed on something so I'm not too anxious about
it. Talking about I guess injecting >> What inject? Oh,
okay. >> Yeah, talk about injecting hormones. See here.
I guess this is going to be like just their whole their whole
like Reddit >> I feel like everyone who is over the age
of 25 that ever talks about anime should be on an FBI watch list.
>> That includes me though. That's [__] up.
They should be watching you.
>> That's me. That'sed up. Okay. I'm uh I'm sort of scatter
here, but I
>> I feel like um Jesus, can this >> my heart is
>> Can you shut up, Blair White? >> [__]
I was just going to watch Blair White cry on on camera. Blair
White's >> Listen, we got a lot of people crying
>> I didn't even see it. I didn't even see it. the
hot dog from 7-Eleven when it's been on the roller for too long.
>> Uh, it's starting to curl, >> starts like blistering
out. >> Oh god. >> Oh, broken. >> Hold on.
>> My heart is so broken.
>> Oh, can we get 7-Eleven?
>> For Charlie Kirk's family. >> You just ruined
7-Eleven forever. Nobody's getting 7-Eleven. This is >> His
wife and his two babies. This has been
not only so horrible and traumatizing to see the video of what
happened and I wish I had never seen the video. I wish I had
never seen the video. And then I guess it just feels like a whole
other trauma to see the psychopathy that I am surrounded by that
we are all surrounded by that there is such an extreme amount
of people in the world that are legitimate psychopaths that are
legitimately
low IQ
disgusting
human beings. And even as I'm saying this, it feels so terrible
for me to even have what feels like hate in my heart for these
people. But seeing that he's being mocked in his death, seeing
the amount of people celebrating it, seeing people show up to
his visual last night, saying the worst of things, saying they're
glad it happened. But like I just Charlie Kirk was in the middle
of a debate of having open dialogue, which is the only thing
that keeps this ship from tipping over, which is the only thing.
>> Okay, I'm going to be real. As somebody who thinks like
some of those sometimes I see those white supremacist protests
that happen that like they come out of a van and they're just
all wearing masks and I'm like, okay, that's like obviously obviously
like the FBI or something. That's like an op. I feel like people
protesting at Charlie Kirk's funeral or Charlie Kirk's vigil.
I feel the same way. It's like, dude, that's just an op. Like
I I don't believe that those are real people that are like, "Yeah,
we're just going to go. We're all going to like Yeah. Oh, you're
sad this guy died."
>> With a mask.
>> This was a thing that was happening a while back. There's
like a Yeah, there's a whole thing. Don't worry about it. I'm
just saying I It just feels like an opt to be on both sides.
Oh,
it sounds like the Purge or some What kind of masks? >> Uh,
no, not like the Purge. Like um I can't remember the kinds of
masks. More like Antifa masks. Like uh like a bandana over their
face. >> Keeps violence at bay is our ability to talk to
each other. If you thought you were taking out some sort of extremist,
you're wrong. You are taking out a moderate. You were taking
out someone who wanted to talk to people. You were taking out
someone who chose peace over violence. Because in this climate,
choosing words over violence is peace. My heart is so Because
in this climate, choosing words over violence is peace. >> As
opposed to what environment? Okay. Didn't he say? So, this is
what we're going to do today. We're going to go through some
of Charlie Kirk's statements cuz uh you know what? I just got
to I got to see it. Okay. I got to see it. I've never really
seen some of the Charlie Kirk, you know, the more inflammatory
things he said. Someone link me a thread. Do we just go through
the whole thread here? >> He's also going to get taken
out of context. Okay. >> Oh, don't worry. There's a whole
there's a whole >> he's going to get taken out of context
or he's going to misrepresent Christian morality and that's going
to be so
>> Yeah. Yeah. There's like a whole thing here that somebody
prepared of what do you call it? Like um >> like actual
context for a lot of these things. Yeah. So, Times Charlie Kirk
directly called for, supported, organized, andor finance uh finance
political violence, a thread with receipts. Now, I think the
big one I've heard about him financing political violence
is
to me that's like a little goofy. So, when he says we should
bail out the Paul Pelosi attacker, he doesn't mean we should
bail him out and let him go. He's like saying I want to know
what actually happened there. This is a little different, right?
Guy gets Let's look at all the bad things he did. No. Uh, that's
not what's happening. scrotum. Am I sure about what? The Paul
Pelosi attacker.
>> He wants to get the person out just so he can interview
them. >> That's what he was saying. Yeah. >> Oh,
okay. Okay.
>> Yeah. So, let's check this one out. Oh, whoops. That's
the wrong link right there. Media Matters doing the idea that
some gay prostitute Oh, sure. Yeah, but that's not um that's
not financing violence or whatever. But we'll keep we'll look.
So, what is this? Charlie Kirk. Joe Biden should be put in prison
and or given the death penalty for crimes against America is
the quote.
Um, Charlie Kirk host, I know what you're thinking. We've got
to get Joe Biden out of the way. Out of the way so we can run
against Cammy. Oh my goodness, is she beatable? It's like black
Hillary on steroids. Is she black? I guess she says she's Caribbean
or whatever. She would she she would be a lot easier to beat
than Joe Biden. Joe Biden is a bumbling, dementia-filled, Alzheimer's
corrupt tyrant who should honestly be put in prison and or given
the death penalty for his crimes against America. I am a >> check
this out >> of
teachers and an educational system
that believed in providing the children
with the full expanse of information that allowed them to then
and encourage them to then reach their own conclusions
and exercise critical thought in a way that was directly intended
to nurture their leadership. I am fully aware that it is because
of that approach
that I stand before you
as vice president of the United States of America. >> I
know what you're thinking. We got to get Joe Biden out of the
way. >> What do you mean? Uh >> I'm I just I hate
the whole thing where it's like I'm an empowered woman. I'm a
careerdriven
woman and I did all of this just so at the end of the day I sound
like your mother. She decided America was going to be your child
instead of a actual child. >> Yeah, just have kids.
All right. Uh, I just thought that sounded pretty cringe overall,
and I can't even really say why. So, I Charlie Kirk's going to
lean into the same thing. Let's see what he has to say. I know
what you're thinking. We got to get Joe Biden out of the way
so we can run up against Cammy.
Oh my goodness. Is she Is she beatable? It's like black Hillary
on steroids. Is she black? I guess she says she's she's Caribbean
or whatever. Doesn't matter. She is. She >> All right,
I can't make any joke because someone's going to get me fired
from the job I don't have. >> Is she black? Is she Wait,
is she black? She's like black Hillary on steroids. I don't know
what that's relevant to, but apparently to Charlie Kirk, it is
quite >> Get Joe Biden out of the way so we can run up
against Cammy.
Oh my goodness. Is she Is she beatable? It's like black Hillary
on steroids. Is she black? I guess she says she's she's Caribbean
or whatever. Doesn't matter. She is she she gives these speeches
and it just has this aura of totalitarianism.
>> By the way, I just want to point out uh people have
argued with me that this guy has charisma. I just I'm just going
to say anybody who's who's tried to say that this guy's charisma,
[__] off. This guy was manufactured. >> My
team says she's Indian and Caribbean.
>> I'll tell you what, she would be a lot easier to beat
than Joe Biden. A lot. I mean, Joe Biden is a bumbling dementia
fililled Alzheimer's corrupt tyrant who should honestly be put
in prison andor given the death penalty for his crimes against
America.
>> Camela Harris, my goodness, there's something that just
kind of is tribal where people are like, I don't know if I want
this crazy person running the country. Okay, I
>> corrupt tyrant who should honestly be put in prison
andor given the death penalty for his crimes against America.
>> wait, hold on.
>> Corrupt tyrant who should honestly be put in prison
andor given the death penalty for his crimes against America.
>> But Camela Harris, my goodness, >> I wait, hold
on. The fact check I got on this is not at all accurate. Okay,
Black Irish. I'm sorry. The fact check I have on this says in
the shared video, Charlie was not advocating for the killing
of the former pres of former President Biden. He was advocating
for the trial of Joe Biden and for what he believed are the crimes
against for what he believed are the crimes against America,
the American republic. And assuming this was found guilty, should
be given the death penalty. That's not actually what he says
there, right? I'm like, wait,
but also hold on cuz I'm going to defend myself cuz you you threw
shots at me. Okay, I do say that Charlie Kirk's charismatic for
this this rage bait is not it's not him demonstrating charisma
for the same reason that people liked Obama. Obama learned how
to talk by replicating his pastor.
If you listen to him speak, he speaks like a pastor. Like he's
giving a sermon at every speech, every address.
He speaks slowly. He speaks short.
Um,
and Charlie Kirk is one of those people. You can tell that he
goes to church, that he listens to his uh preacher, whoever the
he's sitting in on, and he does speak about Christianity, and
he does speak about his faith similar to that of his of of somebody
who is like actually believes in the faith.
I think that's what people will grasp on to on the right, and
they won't pay attention to this. >> Yeah, maybe. Uh, sorry,
breaking news.
I I agree with you that yeah, he's that I don't see it. Like
I can't see it cuz I wasn't raised like as religious as he was
and all of that. But blistering breaking news, guys. The New
York Times actually gotten Discord logs. We've got Discord logs.
And this is where we have first mover advantage right now, guys.
Okay, cuz guess what? Guess who's the best at discerning Discord
logs and what people mean? And it's us, okay? You don't even
have to watch Fox News. They're not going to have any idea what
what emotes mean, what any tone indicators are. Okay? They're
not going to get it. That's why you have to go to alternative
media. You have to go to Twitch. You have to go to Kick. You
have to go to us to interpret this stuff correctly. All right?
>> No. Every person who has ever read The Vampire Diaries
is going to know what this means. >> I have no idea what
that means, but I'm going to continue. After Kirk's suspect joked
that his doppelganger did it before he was arrested on suspicion
of carrying out the assassination, 22-year-old Tyler Robinson
sent friends messages showing that he was closely following news
about the uh FBI and other law enforcement in outside the Utah
in outside the Utah apartment of the suspect on Friday. Oh, cool.
Hold >> All the fantasy books that you read, you've never
read The Vampire Diaries? >> No. The main character literally
has like three different doppelg
Oh sh I just hit clip that. I don't know what that means. Okay,
>> cuz he's not a woman. Very interesting. >> Oh,
wait. What the I hate Twitch so much. What are you doing, Twitch?
I just changed my Twitch my Twitch title to a URL that is for
the clip that it made for me that I don't want that I don't care
about. Anyway, breaking news, guys. New Discord messages found.
Okay, let's check this out. Okay. The day after Charlie Kirk
was killed, an acquaintance of Tyler Robinson's posed a question
to him in a group chat. The FBI had just released two grainy
surveillance images of a skinny young man in a cap and sunglasses
walking at a stairwell on the Utah Valley University campus and
had asked for the public's help in identifying the suspect. Tagging
Mr. Robinson's username on Discord, a messaging platform, the
acquaintance attached the images and wrote, "What are you where
you at? Wia, where you at?" with a skull emoji, suggesting that
Mr. Robinson, 22, looked like the man being sought. Mr. Robinson
replied within a minute. His doppelganger, he wrote, was trying
to get me in trouble. Tyler Charlie, another user wrote, apparently
ingest. Dude, that was Oh god. Is it Wait, four exclamation points.
Did Lauren de Laguna start using Kiwi Farms more and more and
more and now she types with exclamation points, but four times
in a row? >> How many? >> No dot. Well, four dots
if you count the bottom of the exclamation points. That was on
Thursday afternoon around 1:00 p.m. local time. It was not until
later that night, nearly 34 hours after the shooting, that Mr.
Robinson was arrested on suspicion of carrying out the assassination
of Mr. Kirk, 31, a conservative pundit whose was in has inflamed
the political world. The Discord messages were the clearest glimpse
yet of the suspect's demeanor in the hours after the shared with
the New York Times by someone who knew Mr. Robinson in high school,
and it kept up with him in the group chat, which includes about
20 people. He said he had not seen Mr. Robinson in person for
several years. He spoke on the condition that his name not be
used, fearing harassment for being an acquaintance of the suspect.
The Times independently verified that the person who shared the
screenshots attended high school with Mr. Robinson and found
other indications that they knew one another. The screenshots
were shared at the request of the Times or at the request of
the Times. Discord declined to confirm Mr. Robinson's username,
but it matches several other accounts that he used elsewhere
online.
Dude, this is insanely locked down. I've not seen any of his
stuff anywhere online. Am I the only one who's like I feel like
I've looked and I've seen nothing get posted for like any social
media profile. So, it's interesting that apparently this has
kept been kept fairly locked down. People haven't found stuff.
A little weird to me. Anyway, the suspect is expected to be formally
charged by local prosecutors on Tuesday. It was not clear on
Saturday if he had a lawyer. Was the article before or after
this? Kirk shooting Discord. Oh, Discord denies activity. Yeah.
Uh, it was after. This is brand new. So, it's it's after. This
is just dropped, guys. The messages do not shed light on possible
motivation for the shooting, which has been fiercely debated
by people trying to ascribe blame to a political side. A police
officer wrote in an affidavit that Mr. Robinson had recently
discussed Mr. Kirk's upcoming event in Utah with a family member,
and that the two had talked about why they didn't like him. People
who knew Mr. Robinson over the years said that he was extremely
intelligent, followed current events, and spent much of his time
online or playing video games. He was registered to vote but
was not affiliated with a political party and appeared to have
never voted in an election. His parents are both registered Republicans.
After Mr. Robinson joked that the gunman was his lookalike, another
user suggested that the group could turn Mr. Robinson in and
get the $100,000 $100,000 reward that the FBI was offering. Only
if I get a cut, Mr. Robinson responded. Dude, this guy is cool
as a cucumber. What? This guy's not flapped. He's He's unflapable.
He's not flapped.
He's He's sitting there. He just killed this guy and he's like,
"Only if I get a cut, buddy. Let's go. Turn me in. Yeah, get
some money. Get me some money." Anyway, uh someone posted, "Whatever
you do, don't go to a McDonald's anytime soon." A reference to
the arrest of Luigi Manion, who was found at a McDonald's restaurant
and charged with the of a health insurance chief executive in
Manhattan. Mr. Robinson agreed and offered a supposed joke of
his own, writing, "Better also get rid of this manifesto and
exact copy rifle I have lying around. This kind of psychotic.
What the What the hell? Better get rid of this uh exact copy
of that rifle that I have lying around, eh? You know, when another
user suggested that the of Mr. Kirk would lead President Trump
to send the National Guard to Utah, the suspect replied, "In
a red state, not clearly the shooter from California." Around
that time, several news outlets reported the ammunition found
near a rifle at the scene, including engravings referencing transgender
ideology. The truth ultimately was that the engravings included
the phrase, "Hey fascist, catch," as well as lyrics from an anti-fascist
anti-fascist Italian song and a reference to a meme about a bulge.
But at the time, before the exact phrasing of the engravings
was publicly known, the suspect sent messages that suggested
he was closely following the news. "I heard the ammo had something
about trans stuff on it, but they aren't releasing photos or
exact quotes," he wrote. He added, "And also, the claim wasn't
backed by the official FBI, just some dude in a briefing room."
A few minutes later, he joked, "I'm actually Charlie Kirk. Wanted
to get out of politics, so I faked my death. Now I can live up
my dream life in Kansas."
Weird. Is this the Antifa Discord? No, this is a high schooler
Discord. This is like their high school friend group would have
had this Discord. It's probably like a gaming group, right? So,
this was provided by a high school friend. I'm guessing it's
just all high school friends. Mr. Robinson's messages on Discord
appeared next to his avatar, which was from a Garfield comic
and depicted the confused face of Garfield's owner, John Arbuckle.
The police have said that the suspect walked onto campus ahead
of the event in which Mr. Kirk debated students with opposing
beliefs and climbed up to the roof of a building about 400 ft
away from where Mr. Kirk was speaking. The gunman fired one shot,
they said, fatally striking Mr. Kirk and then dropped down from
the roof and rushed off campus. The police said that Mr. Robinson
had implied or confessed that he committed the crime and that
he was the then encouraged by a family member and family friend
to turn himself in, which he did. He surrendered to the police
in southwestern Utah, where he lived, more than 3 hours drive
from the campus where the shooting took place. Following the
suspect's arrest on Thursday night, members of the group chat
on Discord struggled to believe he was actually being accused
of the crime. "Our governor wants to give him the death penalty,
dude," one wrote. Another said, "I truly cannot distinguish if
this is for real. Damn." >> Oh my god.
Turning Point USA just put out new Charlie Kirk merch
and it looks >> Okay, Link. Link, listen. And you never
let a good tragedy go to waste. >> Find the website. What
a what a horrible drawing of him. Why would they do that? >> Oh
god. Here, I'll pull up the picture for a preview first.
Charlie Kirk, send me tea.
Honor the legacy and courage of Charlie Kirk with this exclusive
memorial tea featuring a handdrawn line art illustration of Kirk
raising his fist paired with the powerful scripture from Isaiah
68. Here I am, Lord. Send me. This shirt is a bold statement
of faith, conviction, and leadership.
Oh boy. Oh boy. Uhoh. I can't get a good look at his face. Here.
Here I am, Lord. Send me. Uh. Uhhuh.
need to get a higher resolution thing cuz I should zoom in. I'm
zooming as much as I can. Dude, >> who drew this? And why
is he is he putting up a BLM fist? >> Yeah. I don't know
what he's doing. I don't know why. Why do people do like this?
It's just >> it's not even people. These are his people.
This is his company, >> dude. Is I can't I don't want to
comment on the wife. Like I just don't. But like
>> I don't know. Did you see Did you see the photo she
posted? The video
>> No, it's not that. Not even that. The video she posted
with the casket was like macob. I think that you give people
time to mourn and you give them time
and you give them patience and grace through that mourning period.
But whatever faith that she has, this the spewing of revenge
and vitriol for her husband's death, I think she will come to
regret. >> I probably I think she'll come to regret that.
I dude I I'm going to try to find it real quick cuz I I don't
know why she posted this video. This video is kind of wild. Okay,
the vid you guys know what I'm talking about, right?
Never forget Alex Stein's picture with his dead mom. It feels
a little like that. It's uh it's weird. >> I I say that
she's going to come to regret it because it does seem like they
truly believe in their faith and in like Christianity and like
having revenge on your heart is not a good thing. You aren't
supposed to want to take justice into your own hands. You're
supposed to trust God's will. She's speaking like she's speaking
out of like her like pure emotions, not really through her faith.
That's why I believe that she'll regret it. But if it turns out
she doesn't really believe in Christianity, then like all right,
whatever. >> Wait, correct. Cherry Cherry's talking about
the same thing I'm talking about is Erica Kirk's like overall
demeanor. I'm talking about how unhinged her video was with a
casket. There's like an open casket of her husband and she's
taking pictures like kissing his hands and putting them on social
media. I think it's bizarre.
It's like bizarre and macob. But Cherry's making a totally like
a a point I share and agree with that she's like trying to take
advantage and she's talking about yes, like this is going to
be a rallying cry. People don't know what they've unleashed.
People don't know what they've done. Yeah, it's all a battlecry.
Wait, but show me the photos of what is she doing with the casket?
>> So, these are the photos and she posted. It's just odd
to me. I don't think this is fake. I'm pretty confident this
is not fake, by the way. This video is definitely real. She posted
this video. >> Wait, go back. Go back. >> Go back.
>> That's the color nails that she went with. Bold.
>> I love you. >> Can you even show that? Yeah. >> I
love you. I love you. >> And to not go to go with the almond
shape. You could literally go with the coffin shape. Like there's
a thing called a coffin shaped nail. Just people don't care about
details, but it's fine. Just go ahead. >> I love you. >> God
bless you. >> Like, by the way, these reactions are not
bad. Having the camera there to me is like so offputting and
so weird. I just don't like I'm Yeah, just posting it. Like,
if this was just her genuine reaction, if there's or if like
somebody just recorded it, it's just f it's weird to me that
this would get posted. >> I don't think that's her. That's
my problem. I think well I don't know anything about her. I'm
like trying to give her
the grace of saying that someone more coldhearted
is directing her. >> Wait. Yeah. Just to be clear. Oh,
sure. With the messaging and stuff and firing up the shows and
whatever. >> Like this is somebody at TPUSA that is trying
to take every moment possible. >> For sure. Just to be
clear. Geeky Candy. Zero problem with the reaction. her being
horrified, mortified that her husband has been killed, that she
misses him, that this is the last chance she's going to be with
him in in like a physical sense in any way, right? That this
is the last time she can say her goodbyes. I totally understand
it all. I have no issue with her actual reaction.
>> I have an issue like posting it on social media or whoever
posted it. >> That's why I say that she will come to regret
these moments. And you're supposed to give grace to somebody
to a a woman in mourning or a man, anyone in mourning. You're
not supposed to judge them for these moments. But I do feel like
she's going to come to regret them. And I
I'm sad for her that she's not surrounded by better people to
prevent her from doing this.
>> Yeah. Like you should have somebody who's got your best
interest at heart. Just like, hey, that wouldn't be appropriate
or whatever right now. I
>> I would have told her, go with the coffin shaped nails.
Let's just get >> Never going to have this opportunity
again. Really? >> Look at how duty dirty her shoes are.
No, I'm good. I don't know. Yeah, I'm good on that. But it's
just it's just odd to me. Like it's it's odd. It's just odd.
Okay. Okay. One. Yeah. Anyway. Oh jeez. Jeez, guys. Jeez. I'm
trying to think. Can we get the uh trying to find where this
battlecry quote is as well? >> if I die, my wife befriends
Cherry to get grieving fashion dips. >> Me, too. I hope
that for you, too, Zezy. >> Um, I knew where I saw this
before. Okay, the Pisco tweet. This is This is a risky tweet
for Pisco. I'm sure I'm not sure why you made it. It's like,
uh,
Erica Kirk refers in plural to the evildoers responsible for
her husband's assassination. that they have no idea what they
have done, that they have unleashed a fire, and that the cries
of this widow will echo around the world like a battlecry. It's
like not >> It's just not good language. Not great >> Bisco,
let's hold a mourning woman to every word that she says at her
most emotional, vulnerable points. >> Reconnecting. Wait,
are you going in on Pisco now? >> Yeah, I think she I think
he should grill her. Did Charlie Kirk say this? Yes or no? Yes
or no? Is this I know the coffin hasn't lowered yet, but yes
or no. Did he say this? >> This he like he wants to lose.
I think Pisco's life goal is to be the strongest fighter at losing
for Democrats. >> I don't know. I don't understand Lyan's
post here. Do you understand Lyan's post? I don't get it. I don't
know what this is. >> Who is this guy? >> Looks like
a German World War I leader, maybe. Oh, it's France Ferdinand.
Oh, well, that's not that far off. I didn't I didn't realize
that France Ferdinand. I know the name. I just didn't know the
>> Why do I know that name? >> Uh he's the guy who
got shot to kick off World War I. He was like a diplomat and
him his assassination kicked off World War II.
>> Uh it's a song. Yeah, it is a band. >> Yeah, it's
a band as well. They It's like Take Me Out is like their big
song that used to be >> Yeah. Okay. >> All right.
Well,
>> what else do we got here? Oh, we were we were starting
on like all of Charlie Kirk.
Oh, to go back to Damn, we went through the media matters thing
really quickly, but u just to go back, I understand when you
say the penalty, the death penalty or something, you are implying
like a a trial, but I'm just saying that this is like not anywhere
near that. Uh that's like not anywhere near careful at all. >> Wait,
who? >> For Charlie Kirk, the way he said it. Um Joe Biden
is a bumbling dementia filled Alzheimer's corrupt tyrant who
should honestly be put in prison and or given the death penalty
for his crimes against America. I understand the implication
there is a trial, but you're not saying that, right? >> Yeah,
but I feel like this will be used against people who claim that
um in what direction, though. Never mind. Hold on. I started
talking and I I actually don't know who this wards off. Charlie
Kirk would have been pro death penalty. So I Yeah, he would want
his own assassin to get the death penalty.
>> probably. Yeah, this is just him. This is like a basically
like a a stoking of violent rhetoric is is the claim, right?
>> Me personally, I'm against the death penalty. I actually
think that all forms of the death penalty is a violation of our
eth amendment. >> are you talking about? Me or the
>> Oh, it is the eth Okay.
>> I was like, wait, what's the eth amendment? I don't
hear the eth amendment reference ever. >> You have the
right to not be >> to face cruel unusual punishment. Right.
>> Yes. And I think all forms of our death penalty actually
results in a a pretty drawn out torturous form of death. >> Okay.
Interesting. >> I think the only humane way for the state
to put someone to death is in uh a police officer's
utilization of self-defense like in the >> I don't think
that's really humane. I think you they do it, but >> like
it's warranted. It's it's fair.
>> Sure. But that's not like the but that's not like the
death penalty. It's like it's not like a valid use of Yeah. It's
like it's
a death penalty. That's why I'm saying like the only the only
time the state should ever put you to death is for like um a
police officer's use of >> Sense of humor. I don't >> there's
probably
>> if you're joking with me right now, I'm lost. Just so
you know. >> Do you think I'm joking? No. This is one of
my my genuine beliefs. >> Okay. I Sorry. Now I'm like That's
a joke in and of itself that I have like a a true belief that's
informed. Maybe
in >> I don't know where that guy's coming from right now.
Anyway, here's Charlie Kirk saying America should have public
executions and show them to children.
I remember this one. Wait, what? What the Where's the actual
video? It up here. No, we saw this the other day. Okay. Uh he
was calling for public executions. He said we should have public
executions. We should have them like televised. We should make
money off of them. That was a little crazy. televised public
and something else. It like applied to his case like almost perfectly.
It was very weird. Hold on. Charlie Kirk public
>> Oh, I guess you would say I guess this could be some
people's argument that
um this is demonstrating a lack of political civility by encouraging
a sort of torturous punishment on the American people. Who will
torture? >> Sure. I think it's just in general like a bloodthirsty
rhetoric that people don't like. Yeah, like it's not it's not
even like a it's not like a hard what do you call it? It's not
like a real argument people are making. It's like a
it's just um it's like basically raising the temperature because
the o like the the dichotomy right now like the uh the actual
what would you call it both sides of this is one side saying
well you got this guy killed by calling him a fascist and calling
him and the other side's like yeah well this guy's calling for
public executions he's calling for all this other [__]
right it's it's not precise direct calls to violence if they're
precise and direct calls to violence that pass the Brandenberg
standard people would be getting arrested but they're not >> towards
Hassan's oped where it's this idea that America kind of supports
or just like has this um
violent culture. >> Did you read that? >> I've not
No, we've not read the Hassan OpEd yet. Um somebody asked if
the roommate was found to be trans. Yes, they did. Or they were.
They were. I think they are. I Sorry. So, the FBI has said they're
trans and a family member said they're trans. And I'd say the
the link between them, whether they had a relationship or not,
seems to be >> Well, I I think you would say that they
they hadn't transitioned yet, but they identified as trans, right?
>> Uh, no. I believe they're in the process of transitioning.
I think those videos they had were quite old.
>> yeah. Well, they were in like the DIY HRT. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> Reddit account says they are trans and on HRT. Yeah.
But those photos are years >> of him snow of them snowboarding
because that doesn't look very trans.
>> Yeah, but those Yeah, those are years old. Years and
years and years old.
>> And also,
if you don't notice, um the name of the account,
the username is actually uh or whatever this is, it's Lancelot.
Now, why would you change it from Lancelot to Lancelot with two
T's and an E?
>> Do you We know why, right? Lance a lot with two T's
and an E.
We know I believe we would know this.
>> Oh, well the answer to why you would say >> is
for testosterone
>> is no. The two two T's like it's uh how you didn't it's
how you differentiate between a male and female like version,
>> Yeah. Trans people can't snowboard. That's only according
to Brian Crassenstein. Okay. Other people do think that trans
people can snowboard. No, they they can snowboard, but they they
will do it in a very flamboyant
>> It's really easy to identify a trans person on the slopes.
>> Is it? >> I'm told. >> You're told. Okay.
I got to thank some people for subs, guys. Um, Risling, thank
you for the seven months. Substance, thank you for this the 15
months. Sorry, 14 months. Marty Epstein, thank you for the five
gifted. And Rodmus Prime, thank you for the two gifted.
Damn. Thank you guys for the >> The tweet. People think
I'm being
>> Oh, this is Brian Kraenstein.
>> Sorry. How far How long ago was this? This is 6 hours
ago. Brian Crassenstein. The latest rumor is that Tyler Robinson's
roommate, Lance Twigs, was transgender. There was no indication
that he was transgender. Below is a video of him. And if he was
transgender, which is which there is no such evidence currently.
He is who helped the police catch Tyler. He should be praised.
And then he posts a video of guy snowboarding. Like this person
isn't transgender. Look at this cool switch up they do right
here. Damn. Could a trans do that? Could a trans look that cool?
I don't think so, guys. >> I've never seen a trans person
excel in sports ever. >> Somebody post this and Brian Crassenstein's
response is this is also him. Would a trans person be on the
slopes doing this pose? >> This is in the emergency morning
meetings, by the way. >> Of course. >> I don't know.
I I don't know what the [__] this is. This tweet
was so bizarre to me. Snowboarding is radical. Wait, radicalized.
Yeah. Not radical like that though. Okay. Not radical like that.
Trans people thrive in sports, Jerry. I don't know about that.
Well, sure. It's actually not wrong. >> It depends on what
team they're playing
>> Yeah. Yeah.
Not totally wrong. What was this? Why do I have this?
>> Oh, sorry. This is going into
uh Charlie Kirk versus black culture was something that got posted.
I was asked, "What about black people on clips of Charlie Kirk
on campus?" Well, here you go. Uh oh. Is this gonna is this going
to be good? I don't know if this is going to be good. >> Right.
So when segregation ended, right, black people were when slavery
ended actually, black people were just forced wherever whatever.
Right. So they had nowhere to go. And then there was laws put
in place to put them into prison. And after >> It's okay.
No. No. What's your name, >> guys? What's your name? Jackson.
>> It takes a lot of courage to come up here, but take
a deep breath. Okay. I'm not here to pick on you. And I appreciate
No, it's okay. I know this can be very intimidating to get in
a crowd like this. So, just take a deep breath. Let me let me
make your argument. I'm going to make your argument for you and
I'm going to tell you why I think it's wrong. >> Okay.
Yeah. >> Is that fair? >> Okay. So, the argument
that is being >> Oh, Jesus. Hold on. Hold on. I got to
back it up here real quick. >> And after
>> Okay. No. No. What's your name, >> guys? What's
your name?
>> It takes a lot of courage to come up here. We should
take a deep breath. Okay. I'm not here to pick on you and I appreciate
together. No, it's okay. I I knew I knew I knew this can be very
intimidating and getting in a crowd like this. So, just take
a deep breath. Let me let me make your argument. I'm going to
make your argument for you and I'm going to tell you why I think
it's >> Okay. Yeah. >> Is that fair? >> Okay.
So, the argument that is being >> I mean that shouldn't
be fair, but he'll we'll see. He's probably going to give like
a good version of it. >> He wouldn't be uh he wouldn't
be nice to the guy and then do like a total straw >> That
you want to make is that there's legacies of injustice.
>> And that those legacies impact one generation after
the other. And when those things get handed down, you have what
is a system or a systemic issue that isn't just isolated in 2024.
So the argument that you're making is that what happened in 1954
does impact 2024 of decade after decade after decade. Let me
tell you my response to that. Of course, there is some truth
to that. However, every culture, every per every person in this
audience can point to issues that families or generations prior
had that were able to overcome. So the question is why is it
that black America is one of the only populations that and Native
American populations that have not been able to overcome such
evil horror injustices. Here's my perspective and I want to hear
what you have to say is that the number one way to keep people
out of poverty, lower the crime rate and have a better society
is whether or not you have a mom and a dad around. Would we agree
that's an ideal? >> Yeah. Cool. And so what happened in
is that 25% of black youth had were raised by a single mom. Today
it's nearly 75% about 70%. So that means that that one in four
black kids will have a father around only one in four.
That can't be a real number.
That has to be a fake number, right? Like that has to be that
has to be taking like divorced but present parents and counting
it as a real number, right? I think like parents split but the
father is like in the home or helpful
in inner city number. Well, I can see that being in the inner
cities only. >> That's a that's the number one issue happening
in the country and it's not because of systemic racism. I'd like
to hear what you have to say about that. >> Okay. Um so
I think I um misjudged you at first. Like I when you brought
up the 1350 stat, I had like just assumed that it was like inherently
like eugenics based kind of, you know? So, and that's where my
came from. Like I think we are on the same page that like we
know what the problem is. And that's that's what I mean like
and thank you for saying that cuz I think we actually have a
lot more in common in this country than the media would ever
believe. >> Oh, definitely. Definitely. Right. And like
what what my point was I was trying to saying is I don't think
that we're doing enough to help these black communities catch
up where as like they're underfunded and they're not and they're
overpoliced and there there's this these these factors that are
contributing to like you said these single parent households
like >> so so we're not going to agree on this. This is
where we'll disagree and that's okay. I have more of a view of
Thomas Soul on this where he believes it's far more about culture,
values, and worldview than than stuff and overpolicing. I believe
there's not enough police in black >> stuff and overpolicing
>> black neighborhoods. You're going to disagree with that.
Let's not even get into it. Okay. But I I think we can ask a
question and I want your opinion. Why is it that the single motherhood
rate in black America went from 25% to 75% over 50 years where
America did become less >> What? like why why did it? >> Yeah.
So, what caused black America to go from one of the strongest
nuclear family communities in the in the country to now the weakest
by far?
>> Um, I can't ask your question. >> No, that's okay.
No, that's great. And that and it's again, it's hard to get up
and have these conversations. Here's my opinion. My opinion is
that yes, there was some social welfare that subsidized single
motherhood, which means it's easier to get cash from the government
if you say you are single than if you are married. I think we
can agree that's stupid. That shouldn't happen, right? But I
would love your perspective on this. Do you think in black culture
getting married and staying with one woman for your entire life
is elevated and celebrated?
>> Um, no, not at all. >> I think that's the problem.
>> I I think the problem stem >> Dude, I actually
this is such a I I feel like this is such a boring conversation
to have. Like it's a multifaceted argument and focusing on any
one of them is kind of boring. Like this would be something maybe
interesting to do like a very deep dive on for hours and hours
and hours and hours, but a 10-minute conversation on it's almost
never going to be helpful. I don't think I don't feel that way
at least. Man, I
I thought this was going to be more interesting. I also thought
it was going to be more inflammatory. This is like also nowhere
near as as inflammatory as I thought it was going to be. Blacks
Black people are like most Christians in the in the USA, too.
So, this doesn't have the solution. Oh, are like the most Christian
in the USA. Well, it's not about being Christian, right? He'd
argue like rap music and all this. It's going to be about money
is what it is, right? >> It's going to be it's going to
be that
uh your inner cities in America are like >> rappers black
holes of happiness. They win something, they're like, I want
to thank God. Wait, did you not hear me? >> Say that again.
>> I said rappers rep God all the time.
>> They win like an award and and they're always like,
I want to thank God first and foremost.
>> sorry. Yeah, they do. I but I was arguing the opposite.
I was arguing that like it doesn't have anything to do with >> Oh.
Oh, gotcha. >> So, I was confused for a second, but yeah.
Yeah, I do think rap I mean rappers do, but I just think it's
the whole inner city problem. Lots of those people go to jail.
Um, there's just Yeah, there's just nothing going on. I think
you reach a level of poverty and like there's just a pit that
you can't ever escape from.
Got to fix that problem somehow. I don't know how you fix that
problem. It's [__] It's [__] But apparently
Ethan Ralph is going through this person's um apparently Ethan
Ralph's going through through the Lancelot Reddit account. Okay,
sick. Charlie Kirk trans connection claims demonic Charlie Kirk
killer trans connection claims demonic possession on Reddit.
Was told I was possessed by a demon and then within 30 minutes
kicked out of the house because I started laughing and wouldn't
go to the bishop for a blessing. Later found out they just didn't
like me and they were looking for a way to get me out of the
house. Wasn't even 18 at the time. Wait, that kind of lines up
with the the family member, right? Kind of lines up with what
we read from the family member. Yeah. Jesus. Yeah. Uh the person
who sent me this said, "Yeah, they feel like that is a connection."
>> I think I agree. But hold on a second.
>> We be sending [__] like this shootout is
a shout out to God all day. >> Uhhuh. Thank you, Snoop
Dog.
>> I don't have my OBS open. It was something like uh gangs
rep God all the time and then something about shootouts. Shootout
was blessed or something like that. Let me let me look again.
What did it say? >> Gangs always rep go D. We be saying
like this shootout is a shout out to God all
>> Okay. Okay, dude. All right. Um
looking for where we're going next. Honestly,
I'll be real. I don't want to click through to a Media Matters
article every single time. This person just got other people
to do their homework for them. They're like, "Here's all the
times Charlie Kirk did bad things." media
search Charlie Kirk. It's like I Bro, go grab some clips.
Go grab some clips. Don't just link me to other websites the
whole time. What is this? >> Yeah, I know. Media matters
sucks. >> What you would do to form traffic to your website.
>> Uh, you could, but I don't know if this person works
for the website. Most overly confident disabled woman in America.
Please have a picture in a wheelchair. Jesus. >> Disabled
in what way? I I can't say how this person's disabled.
>> I got >> You think so? >> It's hard to wake
up in the morning. >> they have a They have a wheelchair
there. I assume they were in a wheelchair, but she's a woman.
Okay, guys. Okay, so
I'm just I'm looking around. I don't really see much else. I
might move forward on to just about anything else
we got. It looks like um our buddy Dan also just dropped a video.
Well, he linked a video. Okay.
>> do you want to check this out? I was going to weave
this in tonight. Okay. There's a there's a pretty big pretty
active campaign to cancel Hassan [__] right now based
on some of his stuff. I think we're going to go over the Sitch
tweets as well. Okay. So, I I think we should weave this in.
And Dan just posted this video. And I don't know who Medatron
is. I don't know who this this YouTuber is. I don't know what
they do. >> Hello. Metatron YT.
This guy does Charlie Kirk. I don't think so. He's a historian.
Okay. >> Looks like diet Mike from PA. >> Yeah. Yeah,
kind of. Anyway, I just thought, hey, Dan posted this video.
I'd love to see what this is. I'd love to see We need to talk
about Hassan [__] Let's check it out. Also, I have
to use the bathroom and possibly figure some stuff out. I'll
be right back. Okay, I'll be right back. Today we need to talk
about a very popular content creator and streamer by the name
of Asan Per who is the world's second most popular political
commentator. In the aftermath of Charlie Kirk's assassination,
we need to take some time to reflect on the words and in fact
direct call to actions that have been allowed to be spoken freely
on our social media platforms. regardless of the fact that they
broke not only multiple terms of service which exposes a double
standard but the very basic fibers of dignity and decency.
I will present to you a few clips that have been put together
by fellow content creators who are exposing his diabolical takes.
But ironically, I might end up being demonetized or censored
because of his words on my channel, even though his own words
did not get him demonetized or banned on his platforms. This
isn't two-tier justice. This is 15 tier justice. I'm still making
the video. Before I jump into the actual clips and you see what
I'm talking about, and if you haven't seen it, take a volume.
But before we jump into that, there is one take that I want to
address. A take that has been rather popular these days on social
media, and it's nonsense. So, here it is. The take. >> Okay,
I'm going to pause and just point out that it's totally stupid.
It's totally stupid to go. I just want to point out that I might
get demonetized on YouTube, but he's not demonetized on